la fin de la visite de nicolas sarkozy
en afrique après kinshasa et brazzaville
le président de la république était au
niger aujourd'hui et on a beaucoup parlé
ces dernières heures d'uranium pourquoi
parce que le minerai est très présent
dans le sous sol nigérien et parce que
la france entend ainsi garantir
l'approvisionnement de son parc de
centrales nucléaires les enjeux de cette
visite avec alexandre kara et alain
duban une longue poignée de main entre
le président tandja et anne lauvergeon
la patronne d'areva en une image c'est
tout l'enjeu de ce voyage au niger ce
pays sahélien l'un des plus pauvres du
monde est un véritable eldorado de
l'uranium
c'est du nord du pays que provient plus
de 30% du combustible qui alimente les
centrales françaises
il y a deux ans les relations
diplomatiques s'étaient tendues le niger
accusé paris de soutenir la rébellion
touareg mais avec un pays aussi
stratégique pour la france la brouille
est impossible alors arriva à doubler le
prix d'achat d'uranium
résultat nous avons effectivement signé
en janvier à une convention minière qui
nous va nous permettre sur 35 ans de
développer la plus grosse mine d'uranium
d'afrique
la deuxième plus grosse mine d'uranium
au monde nicolas sarkozy est venu
officialiser cette réconciliation comme
à kinshasa comme à brazzaville il a
promis plus de transparence dans les
relations franco-africaines
c'est le but de mon voyage c'est
vraiment que la france soit aux côtés de
l'afrique on reprenne toute notre place
mais sur d'autres bases voilà ils ont
des matières premières on va les payer
au juste prix trente six heures en
afrique à peine mais 36 heures utile à
la vieille françafrique nicolas sarkozy
me substituer un nouveau partenariat
économique autrement dit l'uranium de la
république démocratique du congo du
niger comme le pétrole du congo sont
désormais des objectifs avoués de la
diplomatie française